the whole idea of making an event-based
commercial is to make it relevant to the
audience that's watching remember this
is a debate I want to show you something
really interesting you know
my companies in Aggregates spend
millions of dollars each month buying
advertising linear television the
networks cable and then onto digital
Google
meta Facebook all the platforms so
creating this content is a constant
ongoing
you know call it activity if you want
sometimes it's a battle because you have
to be creative but years and years ago I
started my career as a film editor
cameraman sound man so it's amazing in
your career how things that you did
decades ago come back to help you
in in your current career and so I I
view myself as an editor number one so I
spend a lot of time thinking about the
creative working on the copy actually
cutting it I still keep my chops up on
Premiere Pro what we're going to do
today
is actually show you how to create a
broadcast network television commercial
from your own home now 15 years ago 10
years ago you could never do this
but today the equipment has advanced so
much so much incredible technology that
you can pull this off yourself
we're going to create for one of my
businesses called Wonder trust which is
the employee retention credit program a
brand new commercial why because next
week in less than seven days there is
the first presidential debates millions
of people are going to watch that and we
want to make sure that we have a
fantastic 30 second in the first hour
and the second hour so we're going to
create it from scratch we're going to
shoot it we're going to edit it and
deliver it to the network all in 24
hours starting right now first thing we
have to do is get the copy so I've
collaboratively been working
on the copy here
with compliance officers
and a whole bunch of other people
um
you know to get this copy done right and
we have to make sure I'm able to read it
in 30 seconds and not scream through it
so in different countries in different
cities I've got a whole bunch of people
here looking at this stock to make sure
that it's going to be compliant there's
all kinds of network rules obviously and
also does it have the right tone it has
the right message and we've been working
on it from the last 18 hours
and above all I got to figure out if I
can read it
in 30 seconds under 30 seconds so the
editor can work with it so
what I'm going to try and do right now
is just use my phone
and put on a timer just to see basically
can I read this in 30 seconds Mr
Wonderful here and there's no debate
about this you see that little reference
to debate how we can make a commercial
that goes into a debate
right off the top that's pretty cool but
of course I gotta start again after
doing that Mr Wonderful here and there's
no debate about this small businesses in
America create over sixty percent of the
jobs but times are tough is there a
solution yes the government employee
retention credit program it supports
small business and you can still apply
even if you received a PPP loan eligible
companies can receive up to twenty six
thousand dollars per W2 employee the
application is complicated so I set up
wondertrust.com a team of live experts
you can trust to guide you through
filing for the ERC go to wondertrust.com
today
Bingo 29 seconds and a half perfect I'm
going to add a couple of just pauses in
here because I can afford it
at this twenty six thousand I want to
put an exclamation mark in so I remind
myself to really make it hot and give it
a comma because this is going into a
teleprompter next so that I can read
this right through the camera lens
always I'm wearing a morning watch I
know I wear three different watches a
day the morning watch because it's 9 A.M
through 10 actually it's 11 now almost
11.
so I'll be switching this around one
o'clock but I'm featuring Jordan today
because I feel you know I want something
clean
so it keeps my mind focused and I love
the style I love the dial always be
thinking with your watch you know you
want to really change your mood change
the watch now this is the studio it's
got some Basics obviously you need a
really good lighting system you have to
have that and that's probably your
biggest expense right out of the gate
sometimes before you get into the camera
equipment but what you want is something
that's going to give you a really good
crisp look now the background's very
important I'm using a background that I
could change let me show you if I wanted
to I could simply go back to the source
and choose one of multiple images that I
have here maybe if I want I'm shooting a
commercial about uh wine I could go to a
wine cellar here's a wine cellar it's
beautiful
this is where we make O'Leary Fine Wines
that's one of the sellers and there
that's a great shot right looks like I'm
in the cellar because I am technically
in the cellar that's the background or
if I wanted to change it after the
production I could actually go the green
screen which is different so we could go
to here but the point is you need a
really high resolution screen to do this
with you want to make sure now let's go
back I'll just show you green now the
thing about a green screen is in
post-production you can basically put
anything you want up so you can change
the background after the fact but we
don't need to do that here we know what
background we want so we're going to go
back to what we're going to be shooting
for the ERC debate presidential debate
commercial so let's go back and set that
up and by the way because there's so
much social media today you have to have
a screen that you can rotate if I have
to shoot in a vertical format I got to
be able to do this you see that
now you're shooting vertically
but we're going to go horizontal because
we're doing Network television 1080p
what we're going to do is we're going to
use a a teleprompter on a tablet and
stick it right in front of the the
screen
and read the script
now the amazing thing about this is the
technology actually listens to you and
keeps Pace with you I'm going to hook my
phone up Bluetooth to this prompter and
it'll use the mic in the phone to
actually listen to me so you can
actually see it on your phone screen as
well as what you're seeing in the
prompter but you're not going to use
this because you're going to look right
into the lens and and basically have to
learn how to not move your eyes back and
forth when you're reading this I'll be
closing all the windows in here so
there's no Reflections that also dampens
the audio just for the sake of just a
test this is the mic I'll be wearing a
lav mic so I'm feeding it now I'll show
you all the different cards because I
actually I shoot this in multiple
resolutions
you know because television needs one
resolution but I want to have an
archival version in 4k just in case
later we reached shoot the commercial in
a higher resolution this is the great
thing so let's start with a quick test
Mr Wonderful here and there's no debate
about this small businesses in America
create over 60 percent of the jobs but
times are tough is there a solution yes
the government employee retention credit
program so you need a laptop if you want
a laptop is great so if you can do a
zoom or Skype is used by some Network so
they have all their own proprietary
links so you want one of those you want
to have a really good camera I'm using a
Sony right now which is the fx9 which is
absolutely spectacular and it gives me a
good feed
that I could send to all kinds of
different devices
there it is multiple feeds coming out of
there right one of them I'm sending to
is where I can record
off a separate screen right here and I
can set the resolution so the the
recording I'm making right now is going
into this card and that's probably the
one that I'll take the file off of and
send it directly to the editors
there's the teleprompter I talked about
right in front of the screen you see
it's in Mirror reflection
that's it
and I have some side cams that you've
seen in other this is running live right
now and bidding us and I've used Side
cams to give you an idea of sort of film
verite I'm streaming networks watching
what's going on at any one time
multiple laptops you really need those
when you're doing production because if
you're editing maybe you're working on a
larger screen this is where I do a lot
of my television from the network calls
me saying look give us this background
give us green give us whatever we want
and then
I'll come in two minutes before rarely
wear any pants because you don't have to
post pandemic Chic is No Pants necessary
and we just basically shoot I do the hit
and then I I record it for them so they
have a feed from here and Native audio
from here which is very valuable in case
there's any screw up in transmission and
then it airs if it's a pre-tape it'll
have the same day or it's live TV which
is often the case Mr Wonderful here and
there's no debate about this small
businesses in America create over 60
percent of the jobs but times are tough
is there a solution yes the government
employee retention credit program go to
wondertrust.com today what's cool about
this is we're going to actually see this
commercial
on top we're going to see it before it
goes to air we'll look at the rough cut
from the editor and we'll also see it
live in the debates
now that's what's so cool about this
this is what's this is the technology
that's changed so much you can now do
this be really responsive to changing in
the market or something shoot a
commercial specifically for a single
show upload it and have 6 10 12 15
million people see it let's put little
wonderful up so the networks have
something to look at
because that camera
is actually
live to New York right now so they can
see that
welcome to the first debate of the 2024
presidential campaign live adviserv
Forum in Milwaukee the whole idea of
making an event-based commercial is to
make it relevant to the audience that's
watching remember this is a debate so
let's check it out
it's here Mr Wonderful here and there's
no debate about this small businesses in
America create over 60 percent of the
jobs but times are tough is there a
solution yes the government employee
retention credit program eligible
companies can receive up to twenty six
thousand dollars per W-2 employee the
application is complicated so I set up
wondertrust.com a team of live experts
you can trust to guide you through
filing for the ERC go to wondertrust.com
today
so that's what I'm talking about is it
going to work we'll find out in the next
48 hours we'll start to see what kind of
yield this commercial has this is the
new way of using digital to determine
what's the content what it should be
should it produce it cut it get it up to
the networks all in a matter of hours
not only is that the future it's the
present today